water jugs are carried carded and pushed
around mikolaiv
across the city water is dispensed
roadside misses move up here
without water for a month there was no
water at all for anything
it's possible to buy water in stores but
many of the 250 thousand residents still
living in mikkolife are now unemployed
and simply can't afford it instead many
people pay with their patients
what comes from the taps can only be
used for washing clothes or showering
the main purified water line for
drinking ran through the occupied city
of kirsan and was destroyed in april
right after that line was attacked some
resorted to using puddle water
this young mother says given everything
people are currently living with lining
up for drinking water trucked in from
odessa is not the greatest challenge she
faces what is the thing the hardest
thing she's dealing with
someone solution is the most difficult
part not being able to plan for tomorrow
unlike the city of kirsan mike alive was
never taken by russian forces
still there is no lasting peace in six
months of war there have only been 22
total days where the peace hasn't been
shattered by rockets or missile strikes
a cruise missile launch from the black
sea destroyed the mika live military
regional administrative office back on
march 29th the horror that unfolded here
is undeniable
37 people were killed i don't want
people in other countries
feel this our war like a show
when you are tired of the war you can
just switch off the tv there is no war
but we are counting the war not in days
but in our in victims more than 120
residents have been killed the regional
governor says death and destruction has
changed everyone
people are afraid and trust has been
eroded our small crew was granted
special permits to report and make a
life but residents called police to
voice suspicion anyway concerned we
might be russian spies
people are afraid
but 15 minutes after the shelling
children are playing 20 meters away from
the courts
i saw this personally the city went into
lockdown recently so police and soldiers
could flush out any potential russian
informers and it may not be the last
time
the war is rarely far from view making
small simple pleasures stand out in
stark contrast
uncertainty itself
one of the only constants in daily life
crystal gavinson global news nick elias
ukraine